[Music]
oh head over boots one of my all-time
favorite country songs i've danced my
wife around the kitchen with that song
more than once country music star john
party is behind that hit and he scored
his fifth number one hit on the country
charts with the song last night lonely
which he is going to perform here live
in just a few minutes
it's the first single off of his new
album that album is called mr saturday
night and the critics not so critical
rave reviews are rolling in party is an
award-winning artist he's got nine
top ten country singles and was named
country music's best new artist back in
2017. he's currently on the road for his
ain't always the cowboy tour and he
joins us now john thank you for being
here good morning so the country music
awards back in 2017 they named you best
new artist but it'd say what have you
done for me lately kind of industry and
i am happy to say that you've been
nominated as of today for minutes ago
musical event of the year and music
video of the year congratulations
congratulations thank you congrats to
midland my boys i love those guys we had
so much fun um
that video if you watch it you know
we're having fun yeah yeah john you
always seem to be having fun you're i'm
having fun right now we're having fun
right now we feel the same about you you
guys feel the same about you and uh
wouldn't want to share this moment with
anybody else
that's always
[Applause]
talk to us about this new album uh and
the song mr saturday night what's the
inspiration behind it
well
this saturday night is
it's fun going guy and
he's out there you know dealing with his
emotions but the best part about mr
saturday night this song
is they the hook is they don't know how
much i missed her saturday night which i
thought was genius
friend benji wrote that song and aft
right after i got done with heartache
medication in 2019 they sent me mr
saturday night and i was like man i just
finished the record i don't want to put
this on hold and and so i let it go back
into the world and hopefully you know
some other artists were cut and as we
went to get our last song list for mr
saturday night the album
uh my friend nicolette texted me she
goes hey don't forget about this song
and then i played it i was like it's
i've always loved it and it just kind of
it's one of those moments where it was
that one song that you didn't know you
need yeah and then it came right in and
boom and it was album title and
everybody's loving it so um it's i
always say that music it works in
mysterious ways yeah and
it's a fun mysterious it's like just
shows up it's like bam
but you know what's not so mysterious is
last night lonely already
off the charts great people really love
it why do you think that resonates
because what's that about i find the
lyrics so relatable writing a number on
a napkin
yeah i like that no um it's it's got a
lot of good scenery and lyrics and
images
and it's a great pickup line a pickup
line wow cause it could be your last
night
[Applause]
i imagine somebody out there
dropping that line yeah right right you
didn't drop it when you met your wife i
i wasn't around yet
no but i love there's a line in santa
cruz i love this song you said wishing
summer would never end summer's your
wife's name yes were you talking about
the season or were you talking about
summer that's for the listener too
i'm gonna say it's about your wife and
he you proposed on the ryman auditorium
so you don't do anything small you must
have known she was going to say yes john
yes well she didn't want to get on stage
i had to drag her out um she she's very
she likes to be in her space and you
know doesn't want to go um being yeah
center stage but i i wanted to propose
to her at something that is a part of my
life and a part of our life yeah
and i want everybody to see it it's like
because this is my life and welcome
welcome to the circus well our other
co-host uh nate burleson he's got the
rona but he's fine
but but nate i know you want to talk to
john party you are missed today of all
days nate burleson hello thank you
i know i know
this isn't a good day to miss um i i had
the rhona past tense gayle um but john i
need to confirm something before i ask
you my question um okay were you you
were a lifeguard right
at one point yes that was a day job for
me when i first moved to nashville oh
wow certified okay certified all right
well i mainly worked on my team
certified
so my my question for you is what is
your advice to these young artists that
are just trying to stay afloat in the
music industry because sometimes they
jump in and they drown
afloat i got you well
i see what you did there that's well you
know um i i guess
if you get down
there's always going to be time there's
new artists you get down but you have to
you have to imagine that we've all been
through
something for
everybody that's
on tv or on doing better than you are
has been in that one spot and you've got
to get over that and you've got to just
get back on you know to the grind and
and always look for something positive
and i know it's hard to do sometimes but
um that's you know he might wake up
the next night with a great song title
and write a song and then it changes
your whole career yes um i could change
it i can't wait to see what you write
about cbs mornings in your next lyric
let's see how you fit that in we also
you gotta also tell us about
inspiration we gotta save time for him
to play the entire last night lonely
stay with us john party coming up he's
gonna perform that number one single
last night lonely we'll be right back